Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today, I’m going to explain a Chinese Comedy
drama film called “Twa-Tiu-Tiann.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
Jack Chen Youxi is a 20 year old melancholic
college student from Taipei.
His grandfather moved to Taiwan from Anxi
in Quanzhou, China in the mid-19th century.
At the tender age of 5, Jack lost his mother.
She suffered from chronic depression and one
day overdosed on her pills.
With no mother and his father always busy
with work, Jack feels lost and has no idea
about his future.
Jack has an eccentric history teacher who
everyone dearly calls Professor P. Sometimes,
the history teacher is also called the Professor
Pig.
Jack and his friends often go to his office
for private classes.
One day, in one such private class, Jack notices
an ancient camera in the Professor’s room
and uses it to click the picture of a wall
clock.
However, he suddenly remembers something important
and hands the camera back to the professor,
abruptly leaving the class with his friends.
The professor is left puzzled by their sudden
departure but he gets even more astonished
when he notices that the wall clock stopped
momentarily after Jack clicked its picture.
Professor P wonders by himself, “is he the
one?”.
It turns out that Jack was rushing to wish
his girlfriend a happy birthday but she breaks
up with him instead.
She tells him that he doesn’t know what
“true love” is after he gives her a teddy
bear, forgetting that she is allergic to soft
toys.
The next day, Jack goes to the Twa tiu tiann
museum with his class accompanied by Professor
P. Twa tiu tiann was the most prosperous area
in Taiwan during the Japanese occupation in
the 1920s.
The museum has a vast collection of relics
from that time such as the water dungeon where
Taiwan’s founding father Dr. Chiang was
imprisoned by the Japanese.
Jack notices the phrase “the flower of youth
is…” carved on the dungeon.
By the Water dungeon, a man gives Jack and
his friends a commemorative coin with Dr.
Chiang’s portrait.
Jack continues to wander around the museum
and comes across the iconic “South Street
Festival” painting of the TTT.
Seeing Jack checking out the painting, Professor
P hands him the same old camera and asks him
to take its picture.
Jack obliges and lo and behold, time freezes
again and the painting comes to life.
Just as Jack begins to wrap his head around
it, he gets sucked into the painting and sent
to 1922 Taiwan.
There, he runs into his friend ‘Black cat’
and his younger brother but they do not recognise
him.
The brothers drag Jack with them to participate
in a cultural procession where he gets into
trouble with a textile businessman named Mr.
Lin.
However, a woman named Ms Ginger, who looks
just like Jack’s mother, saves him.
Ginger also owns a clothing business and is
an arch rival of Mr. Lin.
Jack is stunned to see his mother but she
too doesn’t recognise him.
Puzzled and overwhelmed, Jack passes out from
shock and wakes up the next day in Ms. Ginger’s
home.
He ventures out into the street with Black
cat and his friends to try and understand
what’s going on.
At the market, he and his new mates are threatened
by the businessman’s son Wenshow.
Later, Jack learns that a man named Master
Pig, who looks just like Professor P, works
as a tailor for Ms. Ginger.
Angry at Professor P for sending him inside
the painting, Jack gets into a quarrel with
Master Pig, who denies knowing him.
The commotion attracts the attention of the
Japanese colonial police.
Ms. Ginger again comes to their rescue and
takes the Japanese officers away.
Master Pig then finally comes clean about
his identity and role in bringing Jack here.
The Professor takes Jack to his theatre and
promises to tell him the reason he brought
him here when the right time comes.
It turns out Master Pig is Professor P afterall
and he not only works as tailor but as a play
director as well.
Jack notices a beautiful girl named Rose in
the audience and instantly falls for her.
Rose and her friends are Geisha i.e., girls
that are trained to entertain men with conversation,
dance and song.
To impress Rose, Jack takes on the role of
a tree and the play begins.
He turns the romantic tragedy into a comedy
just to make her laugh, making spectators
laugh till their stomach hurts.
The play is suddenly interrupted when Japanese
officers come barging in.
The Japanese officer reveals that the crown
prince of Japan will be visiting Taiwan in
the coming week and hence, all non-japanese
entertainment will be banned until after his
visit.
However, the Professor and others resist the
Japanese hegemony.
Rose stands up and starts singing a taiwanese
song in defiance of the Japanese occupation,
soon followed by others.
Unable to stop or control the entire crowd,
the Japanese officers leave with their tails
between their legs.
Later, Jack finds a drawing of the present
day Taiwan and attempts to go back but without
success.
The Professor tells the dork that the picture
is incomplete and hence can’t function as
a time portal.
Moreover, one must make a wish with all their
heart to teleport.
It is also revealed that the Professor came
to the Twa tiu tiann with a dream of becoming
rich.
Here, he met Ginger and fell in love.
Ever since then he has been going in and out
of the TTT to earn a lot of money and win
over Ginger’s heart.
Professor proposes a deal to Jack, asking
his help to keep other suitors away from Ginger
in return for getting the painting complete.
Jack agrees.
The Professor continues to court Ginger but
without success.
Meanwhile, Jack becomes close with the Professor's
theatre actors.
He helps them create melodies and new looks
for their play with his knowledge of the 21st
century.
One day, Rose comes to a neighbouring store
where multiple suitors including Wenshow are
trying their luck with Rose.
Jack also rushes there with his guitar and
serenades her with the Happy Birthday song.
Mesmerized by him, Rose formally introduces
herself to him.
Just as they get to know each other, they
are suddenly interrupted by a speech being
delivered by Dr. Chiang Wei-Shui, Taiwanese
doctor and freedom fighter, outside the store.
In his electrifying speech, Dr. Chiang calls
out Japanese occupation and the opium cultivation
imposed on Taiwanese.
The Japanese officers soon start to disperse
the crowd, forcing Jack and Black Cat to hide
in a shop.
Mr. Lin coincidentally brings his son to the
same shop and scolds him for listening to
Dr. Chiang’s speech, jeopardizing Mr. Lin’s
covert business relations with the Japanese.
Mr. Lin reminds Wenshow that their fabric
business is doing well because of Japanese
support and investment.
Jack and Black Cat overhear the whole conversation.
Over the course of the next few days, Jack
and his theatre friends get busy preparing
the Geisha girls for the governor’s party,
where all local VIPs are to be invited.
Jack tells Rose that he came from the future
and about the end of Japanese occupation while
she tells him her wish to one day become a
professional singer.
At the party, Dr. Chiang again clashes with
the Japanese officials but before things could
escalate, Rose defuses the situation with
her charming performance.
Later, Jack steals Rose away and wanders around
the governor’s mansion.
When a group of guards pass by, they hide
in a water dungeon.
At that moment, Jack tells Rose that in the
future everything becomes so easy that people
get lost and forget about their youth and
dreams.
Inspired by Jack’s words, Rose carves “The
flower of youth is…” on the dungeon before
kissing him.
Jack finally realises what true love is.
While returning home, Jack notices Ginger
sneaking out of the house at night to go to
an opium club.
When he reaches the club, Jack finds Ginger
stoned out of her mind with Professor P by
her side.
Reminded of his late drug-addict mother, Jack
scolds the Professor for enabling Ginger and
takes her home.
After coming to her senses, Ginger reveals
that she lost her husband and son to Cholera
ten years ago.
She uses the “high” to momentarily escape
the unbearable pain of losing her child.
Jack figures out that the Professor needs
money to help Ginger buy opium and relieve
her pain.
Ginger admits that she likes the Professor
but can’t commit to him because he keeps
disappearing as if he doesn’t belong in
this world.
It is then revealed the Japanese colonial
propaganda had Taiwanese people convinced
that an addict quitting opium could lead to
their death.
Jack vows to help Ginger and other Taiwanese
who have become victims of opium and begins
a fierce awareness campaign with the help
of Dr. Chiang.
Jack also makes the Professor burn down the
local opium house.
However, this puts Dr. Chiang and Professor
P on the Japanese hit list.
The Japanese officers arrive at Ginger’s
home to arrest the Professor.
However, Mr. Lin interferes and for the first
time, he speaks out against the Japanese occupation.
A chaos ensues.
The Japanese officer accidentally fires his
gun, fatally wounding Ginger.
The Japanese officer orders all hospitals
to not admit patients with gunshot wounds
before heading to arrest Dr. Chiang.
Left with no choice, Jack takes Ginger back
to the theatre, deciding to take her to the
future for treatment.
After everyone leaves, Wenshow notices that
the bullet also hit his father.
Dr. Chiang arrives but by then it is too late
and Mr. Lin dies in his son’s arms.
At the theatre, Jack asks the Professor to
take Ginger to the future while he decides
to stay.
Jack has finally realised his purpose in life.
Chiang is arrested for treason while the working
class Tiawanese are barred from appearing
in public during his majesty prince Hirohito's
impending visit.
Wenshow and his friends join forces with Jack’s
group and plot to free Dr. Chiang.
One night, the Geisha girls distract the guards
and Jack and the boys free Dr. Chiang from
the infamous water dungeon.
Meanwhile, the local Taiwanese opium trader
whose business is being threatened by Dr.
Chiang’s anti-opium campaign, hires Korean
assassins to assassinate the Japanese prince
to frame the doctor.
Dr. Chiang catches wind of the plot and vows
to protect the prince.
Jack and his friends spread rumours around
town that those who don’t attend Prince
Hirohito’s arrival ceremony will get cursed,
hoping to attract a large crowd to make things
difficult for the assassins.
By the time Prince Hirohito arrives, Professor
P also returns from the future.
As the prince heads towards Ginger’s shop,
Jack and Professor P notice the assassins
on the roof, gearing to shoot the prince.
While the Professor hurls the painting towards
the bullet, Jack and Rose throw themselves
at the bullet, hoping to stop it.
However, before anyone has to die, the Professor
clicks a picture of Jack, Rose and the bullet
with the painting, teleporting all of them
to present day Taiwan.
Meanwhile in 1923 Taiwan, Dr. Chiang and other
Tiawanese chant slogans of freedom and equality
in front of Prince Hirohito’s procession.
Dr. Chiang becomes the first Taiwanese to
be arrested for petitioning for freedom and
the colonial government begins hunting down
anyone involved.
Professor P returns to present day Taiwan.
As he proceeds to send Rose and Jack back
to the past, Jack turns to Rose and tells
her his decision to stay.
He tells her that he wanted to go with her
but he likes the way he was before.
Brave and Reckless.
Moreover, the 1920s are her golden days not
his.
He wants to stay back to create his own golden
days.
He wants to tell his people about their history.
Jack then kisses Rose before tearfully parting
ways.
Ginger arrives and Jack embraces her with
tears of joy.
To Professor P’s joy, Ginger then reveals
her decision to stay with him in the present.
Jack wanders inside the TTT museum by himself
and looks at the writings on the water dungeon
that, now, says, “The flower of youth is
the blooming rose” while holding his tears
back.
Jack had completed Rose’s sentence when
he was with her in the past.
All the blissful time he spent with Rose flashes
before his eyes and Jack eventually breaks
into tears.
Later, Jack goes to meet his friends and embraces
them like never before.
They sit by the water and talk about their
aspirations.
The movie then ends with Jack noticing and
smiling at a girl who looks just like a blooming
Rose.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.